Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen. Ähm Tim. Genau, ich bin's. Tim, hallo, Tim.
Genau, ich bin's. Ich bin's, dein Co-Moderator und äh Katalysator und.
Sidekick.
Deinen dein äh ähm wie soll ich sagen? Einsatzgeber Wortzuspieler.
Ja, nee, nee. Jetzt, nee, das finde ich jetzt nicht gut.
So, das mache ich alles. Mach alles für dich, Linus.
Nee, so möchte ich nicht hin.
Soja nun auch wieder nicht. Na ja gut, also willkommen bei der Tim Prit Love Show.
Tim.
Mein Praktikant Linus Neumann sitzt mir gegenüber und äh hat ein paar Informationen zusammengetragen und die wollen wir heute besprechen. Hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik Ausgabe neunundzwanzig. Wir sind ja dreißig sehr nah, du weißt, was passiert, wenn man dreißig wird.
Nee, nicht, zum Glück, weiß ich noch nicht. Nee. Nee.
Nee? Nee. Die Leute fangen an, dein Ernst zu nehmen.
Ja, das, das ist genau das, wovor ich Angst habe.
Na, den Podcast könnte es gut tun.
Ja, aber sonst.
Doch, doch, nee, das ist gut. Dreißig werden, ist geil. Wirst du's merken? Also, die Leute sind auf einmal, auf einmal wirst du einfach ernst genommen. Wo du dich immer wunderst, warum nehmen die Leute mich jetzt schon nicht ernst?
Und dann nehmen sie dich sogar dann ernst, wenn's eigentlich gar keinen Anlass gibt, dass man ernst genommen werden sollte. Ja, das ist äh.
Eigentlich eher selten, aber äh.
Na ja gut, aber kann ja machen, kann ja mal vorkommen.
Also es ist so ein geheimer Club. Das ist eigentlich nicht dreiundzwanzig, sondern.
Wir geben dir dann auch so einen Umschlag.
Ja
Ja, auch so ein Umschlag äh,
wurde hier weitergereicht hier der Flug des Condor äh unser Freund Julian Assange immer für eine Meldung gut,
so auch dieses Mal hat äh des Nachens sich sein Batman Kostüm angezogen und gegen seine Auflagen verstoßen,
beziehungsweise er möchte gerne nach Equador, er hat's bisher nur in die Botschaft geschafft und äh hat sich da äh eingenistet und brüht da jetzt gerade irgendwas aus,
bin mir nicht so sicher, was äh seine Erwartungshaltung ist, da äh ist ja nicht Equador auch schon mal irgendwie mit seinen WikiLeaks auf den Geist gegangen.
Nee, ähm Equador war so eine Geschichte, dass ihr etwas in den,
Ähm also erstmal irgendwie zweitausendzehn hatte, glaube ich, der Vizekanzler Kanzler von Ecuador. Julian Assauce schon so politisches Asyl nahegelegt,
in Equador. Und dann sagte aber der Raffael Gorea,
der äh Präsident gesagt, nee, äh das ist zumindest keine offizielle Einladung gewesen sei, sondern irgendwie eine eine persönliche Meinungsäußerung, dass also jetzt quasi kein offizielles Angebot gebe von Ecuador,
und ähm dann im Rahmen dieser ähm äh Botschafts-Leagues da, wie wie ähm,
wie wie nannte man Cable Gate? Ähm im Rahmen der Cable Gates äh gab es dann irgendwie eine bisschen diplomatische Verstimmung auch zwischen Ecuador und den USA, aber die gab's ja nicht zwischen jedem Land. Und den USA war eh, weil die ja.
Volleyball drin stand, dass.
Wie doof die anderen alle sind.
Ja und sie sich äh Sorgen machen um alle. Ihr seid alle korrupt und immer blöd, ne.
Naja und dann ähm gab es ja vor, ne, das war ungefähr vor einem halben Jahr oder so,
diese schöne Sendung ähm in der dieser Fernsehshow, die Assange bei Russia Today hat, also der World Tomorrow heißt die glaube ich, ähm,
da hatte er ja jetzt auch den äh Raphael Korea als Gesprächspartner vor, also ist ungefähr ein halbes Jahr her, ich kann jetzt gleich mal gucken, wann das wann das war. Und die Sendung, die ist eigentlich echt ganz cool, weil die ähm,
Die beiden unterhalten sich da irgendwie so und hauen die ganze Zeit so antimperialistische USA-Witze raus so, irgendwie so. So, ja äh, welche, welches ist das einzige Land, wo es keine Revolution geben wird? USA, die haben keine amerikanische Botschaft.
Weißt du so,
und und und so zwei äh so zwei Feinde der USA äh lächeln, machen sie die ganze Zeit so Witz, wissende Witzchen so, ne, so, immer so.
Stehe. Aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass die so auch so na gut, so richtig überrascht bin ich jetzt auch nicht.
Sie haben sich sehr gut verstanden in dieser ähm in dieser Folge, ja?
Verstehe und jetzt macht er ihn sozusagen Stress, indem er da in der Botschaft aufläuft und jetzt muss er sich Equador da positionieren. Ich frage mich, haben die eigentlich überhaupt eine Möglichkeit, ihn legale außer Landes zu kriegen? Ich meine, wenn die Briten jetzt sagen, nee, der fliegt hier nicht weg, äh.
Also es ist,
Es gab auf Twitter wurde schon so gesagt, ja ich will da mal auf den Kommentar von Linus gespannt, äh der wird ja wahrscheinlich wieder platzen über den Unsinn oder oder was auch immer. Ich persönlich muss erstmal sagen, wenigstens passiert mal was,
Das finde ich schon mal gut. Und ähm,
Die Angelegenheit ist natürlich tatsächlich sehr spannend, weil offiziell gibt es ja nach wie vor nirgendwo irgendwelche Anklagen gegen den. Ähm und die Situation ist, es gibt irgendwie einen Haufen von äh,
öffentlichen Aufrufen in den USA, ihn umzubringen. Es gibt aus dem Strap vorliegt die Information, dass es eine ein Seelement gibt, also eine in der Schublade liegende Anklageschrift.
Die rausgezogen wird, wenn's.
Die rausgezogen wird, sobald man ihn hat äh und das sind irgendwie angeblich vierzehntausendfünfhundert Seiten oder so. Ähm hat aber, habe ich jetzt noch nicht gelesen und ähm also es ist ja auch,
also das ist ja schon relativ ähm glaubwürdig, dass die USA irgendwie so eine Anklageschrift da haben. Ja, und sich den äh fischen wollen. Sie haben ja auch vor,
ging dann nicht großartig durch die Medien, aber sie haben wohl Smari und Jeremy Zimmermann, Jeremy Zimmermann von,
ähm und Smari hat da auch irgendwie mal im Umfeld ein bisschen gewirkt. Äh wurden auch irgendwie an Flughafen letztens mal äh rausgefischt und äh äh interviewt und ähm,
Also da gibt's durchaus nach wie vor Interesse und das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu verleugnen,
Ähm aber genau, worauf ich jetzt hinaus wollte, ist dieser der Assange, beantragt quasi politisches Asyl,
Und es gibt ja aber eigentlich in keinem Land irgendwo eine eine Anklage gegen ihn. Das heißt, ähm es gibt nicht so wirklich irgendwie was,
Es gibt einerseits gibt's nix, wo die wo wo Ecuador ihr jetzt offiziell jemandem auf die Füße treten würde, wenn sie ihn,
Ihm das Asyl gewähren. Also es gibt nichts offizielles, was sie, was sie falsch machen, weil es gibt ja keine keine.
Keiner sucht ihn offiziell, außer den Schweden, die mal mit ihm reden wollen.
Wie wollen wir mit ihm reden, ja? Also es gibt äh keine äh es wäre jetzt nicht irgendwie sowas wie Fluchthilfe oder so, wenn Ecuador sagt, klar, kommst du zu uns?
Fragt sie natürlich auch, wie man dann offiziell äh Asyl überhaupt rechtfertigen kann, wenn nichts los ist.
Genau, das ist die, das ist die andere Seite. Und ähm was sie den Weg, den sie da gehen, ist natürlich irgendwie dieses, was ihm in den USA droht und dass er jetzt natürlich so diese Leute hochhält, es wird gab ja viele,
ähm,
politische Figuren, die dann nach den, gerade nach dem Cable Geld gesagt haben, äh ja, wenn's nach mir geht, äh knallt den, knallt den ab oder lasst äh hängt den auf oder ja, sie haben ja sogar für
nicht rechtsstaatliche äh Maßnahmen irgendwie äh wie gegen Terroristen
aufgerufen. Und das ist ja durchaus äh sage ich mal etwas, was man bei so einer Überlegung in die Waagschale legen kann. Ich persönlich glaube aber viel eher,
Also, es ist ja so, wenn wenn Ecuador jetzt sagt, nein,
Dann steht unten vor der Haustür die äh die Metropolitan Police äh in dem Moment, wo wo Julian da rauskommt und schnappt sich den, weil der, also der kann jetzt nicht wieder zurück auf die.
Jetzt haben sie vor allem mal was gegen ihn, ne?
Genau und jetzt hat er, hat er gegen den Kram verstoßen und noch viel schöner, ähm wer hat denn die Kaution bezahlt, ja? Da waren ja auch ähm da waren doch irgendwie Promis dabei, äh die werden jetzt die Kohle erstmal nicht wiedersehen, ne?
Das sind so zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro oder so was in der Größen
habe ich gehört oder Pfund. Also auf jeden Fall ein Batzen Geld, ja, das hat jetzt nicht unbedingt einer bezahlt und wahrscheinlich sind's jetzt auch alles nicht unbedingt so Leute, äh die es jetzt sonderlich schmerzt.
Ja, aber ähm.
Weiß man aber auch nicht.
Also das äh Michael Michael More war da ja zum Beispiel bei ähm ich.
Michael Moor. Ja. Mhm.
Ja, jetzt ist halt die Frage, ähm also da das Geld ist äh Zweifelsfall ähm weg,
Zumal wenn er jetzt diese, ja genau, darauf wollte ich eigentlich hinaus. Also, er hat.
Behalten Sie jetzt auf jeden Fall gern.
Wird jetzt erstmal einbehalten, denke ich so. Das Blöde ist natürlich, wenn der,
Also das Risiko, was er eingeht mit dieser mit dieser Flucht zu der Botschaft ist enorm hoch, gesetzt den Fall, dass sie ihm das Asyl nicht gewähren.
Dann hat er ein riesen Problem. Und dann wird er auch überall in Zukunft im Knast sitzen wegen Fluchtgefahren.
Überall im Sinne von wo.
Wo auch immer man ihn als nächstes hin tut, der wird im Knast bleiben,
Ihnen wird ja, solange er also äh in in U Haft in in Anführungszeichen oder was auch immer. Also das nächste Land, in das er ja fliegen wird, ist ja Schweden. Es sei denn, er, er, er er spielt jetzt noch gegen äh am EuGH
So und da wird Schweden natürlich auch sagen, mein Freund kommst, man durfte sofort hier äh mit in den Knast, bevor du wieder in irgendeine Botschaft rennst, ja.
So, das heißt, ähm und er also äh wenn wenn Ecuador das ablehnt, hat er auf jeden Fall erstmal ernstzunehmende Probleme in in England und in Schweden und so weiter. Und,
Deswegen glaube ich, dass er dieses Risiko da nicht eingehen würde, wenn er nicht in Ruhe schon mal mit mit ähm Ecuador gesprochen hätte darüber, äh ob's ob er da Asyl bekommt oder nicht,
muss jetzt dazu sagen, wir nehmen am Freitag den äh zweiundzwanzigsten auf und es ist eigentlich damit zu rechnen, dass heute noch die Entscheidung äh gefällt wird,
ähm.
Wird man hier mal ein bisschen drücken auf,
vielleicht müssen wir ja noch eine Schlusskapitel einführen.
Ja, also ähm,
Auf jeden Fall spannende Sache und auch so von der, von der Überlegung her. Und jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten Problem. Ähm wie kommt der da weg, ne? Ich hatte meine erste, meine erste Theorie war, der ist schon längst in Ecuador,
damit die Flucht irgendwie oder damit die Abreise irgendwie nicht großen Wind macht, haben sie, haben sie's halt einfach schon.
Aber wie soll er denn da hingekommen sein?
Ich habe mir das Gebäude angeguckt, die könnten da wahrscheinlich, also die haben ja Hintertür, gehst dahin, vergeht ja vorne rein, kommt hinten sofort wieder raus und fährt äh fährt irgendwie zum Hubschrauber oder was?
Schon möglich. Problem ist aber du hast Recht, der hat ja diese elektronische Fußfessel. Das heißt, die die äh die äh englischen Behörden wissen schon relativ sicher, wo der ist,
Fuß abgehakt oder so.
Oder die Fußfessel abgemacht.
Das ist halt die Frage. Ich meine, das wäre dann ein Verstoß gegen seine äh Bale-Auflagen.
Na gut, aber das hat er ja eh schon gemacht. Dann kommt's ja darauf auch nicht mehr an. Sagen, hier guten Tag, ich beantrage äh Asyl und Netflix.
Habt ihr ja sicherlich da, Asyl, können wir auch da nachmachen. So,
hat er da erstmal ein bisschen die Elektronik weggefeilt. Keine Ahnung. Ich meine, darauf ne? Ich meine, wenn wenn sozusagen,
Das würden sie wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen, weil ich habe keine Ahnung, über die Technik von Fußfesseln, aber ich meine, wenn man eine baut, dann ist da definitiv auch äh irgendwie Beschleunigungs äh äh Sensor drin, der irgendwie auch feststellt, mit ich werde jetzt gerade abgesägt.
Ja, also das äh ich denke auch, dass die Briten sind schon halbwegs im Bilde, ne? Und würden zur Not auch ordentlich äh Rambazamba machen, wenn er schon Ausländer. Also unklar, keine Ahnung.
Aber genau, was ist jetzt, was ist jetzt, was ist eigentlich der der Knackpunkt bei der Angelegenheit? Ähm Ecuador hat jetzt da natürlich eine relativ problematische,
Situation und wird jetzt vermutlich grade sehr in den diplomatischen Verhandlungen stecken mit den anderen Ländern, um da mal abzufühlen, wie viel Ärger sie sich einhandeln, wenn sie das jetzt machen. Ähm weil,
es ist relativ klar, dass das ein Afro gegen Schweden ist, Afro gegen die USA und ein Afro gegen ähm England, unabhängig der Sache, einfach nur rein.
Britannien heißt das. Großbritannien. Großbritannien und Nordirland, um genau zu sein. Wir könnten uns auch auf Vereinigtes Königreich einigen.
Ja, das äh UK okay, also.
Sagst ja auch nicht Bayern, wenn du von Deutschland sprichst.
Nee, das ist sowieso nicht.
Wollte ich nur mal kurz, aber auch egal. Ja, ja. Passt schon.
Der sagt.
Jeder tritt ein Tritt, jeder Stoß, ein Franzos.
So ungefähr steht jetzt da die äh ungefähr so steht jetzt Ecuador da. Die müssen sich jetzt wirklich überlegen. So was sagen die USA dazu? Und ähm das Interessante ist, rein offiziell wie gesagt, den sucht ja keiner. Also äh
äh also den suchen zwar Leute, aber es gibt keine Anklagen. Also aufm Papier ist die, ist die Angelegenheit völlig in Ordnung, aber natürlich wird das jetzt in den, in den diplomatischen Hinterzimmern,
Ähm grade muss muss Äquador sich jetzt überlegen, wie viel Ärger handeln sie sich ein, wenn sie das machen?
Das wäre wahrscheinlich überhaupt das Schlimmste für ihn und so, dass die sagen. Ja äh Herr Assange, Asylantrag ist ja schön und gut so, aber,
Erstens liegt ja nichts gegen sie vor, zweitens sind sie offensichtlich total bedeutungslos. Gehen sie bitte wieder und bringt er sich um.
Also ich bin ich bin sehr gespannt, was wir können ja mal.
Naja gut, also ich meine, nehmen wir mal an, dass die große das große Verschwörungszenario, ja, was eher so ein bisschen an die Twitter Wall äh malt, äh dass da was dran ist.
Ja? Äh die USA haben schon so einen ein so einen Plan irgendwie in der Schublade, der ist mit Schweden abgesprochen
alles ist der totale Fake, irgendwie auch so äh die Mädels, die da vor Gericht gezogen sind, das ist alles nicht wahr und das ist alles nur ein ein großer, gemeiner Plot, um ihn irgendwie schnellstmöglich dem Henker äh zuzuführen, so wenn er das wirklich glaubt,
dass das so ist, unabhängig ob es so ist so, dann ist natürlich dieser Schritt für ihn irgendwie konsequent, weil für ihn ist dieser äh Schritt nach Schweden irgendwie quasi,
Der Auslieferungsantrag äh.
Die Interpretation ist ja vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt. Also warum wollen die ihn in Schweden haben, wenn sie also die Idee ist ja, dass Schweden, dadurch dass sie gar keine Vorwürfe gegen ihn haben oder oder.
Auch Vorwürfe gibt's.
Aber keine offiziellen äh keinen offiziellen Anklagen oder sowas. Deswegen quasi in dem Moment, wo der bei ihnen ist,
genau in dieser Position wäre,
in äh ach hier ist er ja, guck mal, zack ab in die USA. Dass das, das ist ja quasi das befeuert ja quasi diese Idee. Ähm oder.
Weil sie ihn ja nicht befragen per Fernbefragung zum Beispiel, was ja auch äh hätten durchaus tun können.
Angeboten wurde. Ich weiß nicht, wie üblich das ist, hatten wir ja schon mal auch drüber gesprochen. Aber das befeuert natürlich den Gedanken. Und wir haben ähm, ich habe mich vor ein paar Wochen nochmal mit jemandem unterhalten, der da auch ähm,
relativ nah dran ist. Du kannst dich dran erinnern. Ähm der halt auch meinte, na ja, wenn du
Julian, wer ist würdest du auch nicht sagen, alles klar, ab nach Schweden, sondern äh du würdest halt auch irgendwie Wimmern mitm Daumen im Mund unterm Bett liegen. Und ähm da konnte ich dann auch relativ wenig entgegensetzen, ja.
Nee, klar, das ist nachvollziehbar. Ich meine, für ihn geht's da auch um um die Haut und äh.
Und ähm was natürlich,
nicht so wirklich mit äh also was was man einfach merkt ist, dass äh dass offensichtlich Wiki Leaks, weil es immer noch so Julian Zentristisch ist oder Julien zentriert ist, äh nicht,
Operation operieren kann,
wirklich im Moment und ist auch relativ klar, ich meine, wenn der der sitzt da ja nicht irgendwie besonders unbehelligt in in in diesem äh Land gut da, ne, also das ist ja jetzt nicht so, als könnte er da ähm,
frei sein, seinen Wikileakskram abmachen und die großen, neuen Leaks rausballern.
Ist bestimmt ein schönes Land, aber am Ende kommt er da ja auch irgendwie nicht weg. Also ich meine, Asyl heißt ja dann auch so viel wie da bist du dann.
Ja. Also der wird sich da schon ganz,
ich meine, ihm geht's ja irgendwie darum, zu überleben und nicht in die USA kann, äh ist relativ klar,
mit Europa äh abgeschlossen hat, nachdem was was ihm jetzt mit den mit äh dem Vereinigten Königreich und dem schwedischen Königreich äh widerfährt, ja.
All diesen Königreichen.
Ja, in den, also mit den ganzen Königreichen hat er auch keine Lust mehr, Australien, dritter Kontinent, auf dem er äh sich nicht mehr blicken zu lassen braucht. Ja, dann bleibt ja nur noch irgendwie Südamerika oder A.
Man macht da einfach Retuerman, ne? Geht da in Rente, wie alt ist er denn eigentlich überhaupt?
Der müsste so dreiundvierzig sein.
Echt. Guck mal.
Schätze ich jetzt.
Bestimmt geheim,
Juli einundsiebzig. Ja, einundvierzig. Habe heute Geburtstag.
Wann hat der Geburtstag?
Dritten Juli nächste Woche hat er Geburtstag.
Ja, ab in Ecuadors schön hier.
Übernächste Woche wird er zweiundvierzig.
In der Sonne.
Na gut, genug gewitzelt. Äh das ist auf jeden Fall die Ist-Situation. Wir sind gespannt, ja. Äh wir haben auch unsere Korrespondenten direkt am Gerichtssaal. Sollten sich irgendwelche neuen Erkenntnisse äh ergeben?
Dann piept das hier gleich. Ja.
So, kommen wir zum nächsten Abteilung. Gute Abteilung, gute Nachrichten.
Ja ähm der bitte?
Ne? Gibt's ja hier auch.
Gute Nachrichten. Äh Equa, du hast wenigstens mal vernünftiges Wetter im Gegensatz zu Berlin jetzt.
Akta ist,
wenn das hier mit dem Wetter so weitergeht, beantrage ich auch Asyl.
Meteorologisch verfolgt in ähm,
Der Ausschuss, der federführende Ausschuss fragte, nämlich der Ausschuss für internationalen Handel im Europaparlament, der Inta hat sich mit neunzehn zu zwölf Stimmen gegen die Ratifizierung von Akta ausgesprochen,
Das heißt, auch das müsste dann jetzt der fünfte Ausschuss sein, der die Ablehnung empfiehlt. Ähm.
Der fünfte europäische Ausschuss.
Der fünfte Ausschuss des Europaparlamentes, genau, ja, der die äh Ablehnung empfiehlt,
Aber wir wissen natürlich, äh vierter Juli, also einen Tag nach Assangers Geburtstag. Ähm ist dann die äh um gegen zwölf,
die Abstimmung im Plenum. Das ist äh die endgültige und wichtige.
Also theoretisch könnte das Parlament nach wie vor dafür stimmen, auch wenn es generell eigentlich unüblich ist in äh Parlamenten jetzt allen Ausschüssen zu widersprechen.
Ja, also ist jetzt ist unüblich, aber man hat ja schon Pferde kotzen sehen direkt vor der Apotheke. So und das äh,
muss man halt mal, äh muss man halt mal überlegen. Aber es sieht im Moment sehr gut aus, ja, aber wir äh das sieht man ja auch gerade beim Fußball, es ist ja gerade Fußball äh Europa Fußball.
Genau, das Spiel ist nämlich auf dem Platz.
Dauert neunzig Minuten, Ball ist rund.
Am Ende gewinnt Deutschland.
Ja und da ist jetzt halt die Frage.
Ja, das ist die Frage. Na, okay, also ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Offensichtlich hat der ganze politische Druck da äh äh doch eine Menge bewirkt. Ja, was man ja noch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit,
ähm nicht nicht wirklich von hätte ausgehen können, in gewisser Hinsicht,
Polen hat's irgendwie gerissen. Ja, ich glaube, der Widerstand in Polen, dieser schlagartig massiv auftauchende äh Druck, hat dann auch erst den Westen so richtig mitgezogen,
Und ähm naja, können wir jetzt viel drüber philosophieren. Machen wir jetzt aber nicht.
Gibt Ägypten vielleicht noch an der Stelle zu empfehlen, so einen kleinen Artikel hatte Markus da mal zusammengeschrieben für digitale Gesellschaft, äh wie baut man eine Acta-Kampagne, wo also ein bisschen die äh das,
das Resümee äh so ein bisschen gezogen wird, was äh was wurde gemacht, was hat funktioniert und so weiter, das äh verlinke ich mal. Wer Lust hat, das zu lesen, so es soll so quasi so ein bisschen was haben wir gemacht und irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Auto.
Gibt's auch auf Englisch.
Schön. Gut. Kommen wir zu den nächsten äh Schmerzen im Hintern, das Leistungsschutzrecht.
Ja, da gibt's jetzt von.
WTF überhaupt, den irgendwie die Koalition in der letzten Zeit rausgehauen hat. Erstaunlich.
Er ist Metronaut hatte das sehr schön äh endlich äh Kiosk Besitzer werden äh für das Auslegen von Zeitungen äh bezahlen müssen, ja. Das fand ich auch noch einen sehr schönen Vergleich. So auch verlinken. Retro.
Ja, aber jetzt hat sich auch äh D vierundsechzig äh mal erhoben und mal eine äh Aktivität angekündigt. D vierundsechzig, die SPD nahe, äh ich denke, das kann man so sagen, ne? Äh netzpolitische äh Aktivisten.
Plattformen, die sich da letztes Jahr gefunden hat. Und ist dagegen.
Ja, die haben sind dagegen und haben jetzt auch mal
eine ein bisschen Kampagnenmaterial zur Verfügung gestellt und zwar haben sie basteln lassen, so ein äh Wordpress-Plugin und aber nee, jetzt geht bloß eigentlich mit so einem URL-Shortner, das heißt, man
irgendwie, wenn man jetzt einen Link auf eine
sagen wir mal auf auf eine Presseerzeugnis twittern möchte, dann man den Link durch äh ihren URL und wer dann auf den Link klickt, landet erst bei so einer,
Landing-Page, in der dann über die die Nachteile der Idee eines Leistungsschutzrechtes.
Mhm. Soll ich mal ausprobieren? Zack. Und dann,
Leider können wir dich aufgrund des geplanten Leistungsschutzrechts nicht zum verlinken Angebot weiterleiten. Denn du hast,
Was? Was ein Linke klickt, der dich zu einem Onlineangebot eines Presseverlags geführt hätte. So so. Aha.
Ja, da haben sie also eine, so eine dahinter verbirgt sich so eine Blacklist äh an den Verlagen, die irgendwie dafür äh Lobbyarbeit betreiben.
Ja. Betreiben. Hab's gerade mal mit Welt DE ausprobiert. Das scheint äh offensichtlich vertreten zu sein. Das wundert ja auch nicht.
Ja und genau, dass das dann noch weitergeführt als Wordpress Plugin. Das heißt, da läuft dann einfach so ein kleiner Substitut durch und.
Alle Links sozusagen und.
Nimmt alle Links von dieser Blacklist und setzt dann diesen diese Landingpage davor, ja? Also relativ, ist ja relativ einfach gebaut, ne? Also irgendwie.
Ja gut, aber er macht das so dynamisch beim Ausliefern der Artikel, ändert das jetzt nicht in der Datenbank oder so?
Genau, geht einfach dynamisch beim nö, das also denke ich nicht, ich habe den Code jetzt nicht gelesen, aber äh das wäre jetzt sehr dumm, das äh das äh nicht in.
Okay, das haben sich eine ganz pfiffige Idee, weil das macht jetzt erstmal nichts kaputt. Ist natürlich auch ein.
Eignet sich schön zum Klick-Aktivismus, äh Plug-in rein und fertig. Klickt,
Ja, also schöne, schöne Kampagne und auch ähm man sieht da relativ gut die so so zügig wie das kam, kann man ja davon ausgehen, dass sie's in der äh in der Hinterhand hatten.
Und äh schön aufbereitet, das Design, bei denen ist ja sowieso immer sehr äh sehr äh gefällig. Und ähm ja,
schönen äh sich des Themas angenommen. Kann man so loben und hoffen, dass das irgendwie Verbreitung findet. Und äh wie gesagt, es macht's einem relativ einfach.
Genau. In der Koalition selber geht's äh da glaube ich äh ganz munter hin und her. Da sind jetzt auch alle nicht unbedingt so überzeugt, dass das Leistungsschutzrecht, ich glaube sogar, dass C-Netz äh hat sich dagegen ausgesprochen.
Ja, Zähne.
Also dagegen ausgebrochen, sagen wir mal so in dieser üblichen Formulierung mit suboptimal und äh,
Hast du noch gar nicht gesehen.
Nee, doch, ich wollte C, C minus Netz DE, da landet man halt bei der Telekom,
Ja. Das sind schon Spezialisten. Was ist denn jetzt die Seite von denen? Weiß ich nicht. Zehn Netz. Zehn.
Zehnels Punkt Info. Ah ja. Sind ins Ausland abgewandert.
Leistungsschutzrecht hemmt, Innovation fördert sie nicht. Ähm kurzes Statement, nee, gar nicht so,
Ja, also okay, immerhin, ja, man sieht ähm,
Es muss klar sein, dass ein Leistungsschiedsrichter, das ein ökonomischen Ausgleich schaffen soll, nicht das Grundrecht auf Informationsfreiheit oder das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung tangiert. Äh.
Ja, also die Linken hier auch ganz fleißig äh auf ähm Kalbieren als Artikel, Telemedicus, Media,
Info et cetera, aber eben auch Wirtschaftsverbände wie Bitcoin, die eben auch nicht so ganz äh glücklich damit sind. Also die die wirklich eng, extrem eng, engstirnige
bevorzugt von Presseverlagen, ja? Einhergehend auch noch mit so einer vollkommen unklaren Definition,
wo Presse jetzt eigentlich anfängt und aufhört, ne, weil man ja im Prinzip auch alle Blogger genauso gut mit äh einbeziehen könnte, wenn man von Journalismus spricht, ja.
Ähm also ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht. Äh wir wissen alle, äh äh Politik kann manchmal grausam sein, aber dieser Vorschlag erscheint mir halt wirklich auch so haltlos zu sein,
dass ich mir irgendwie unmöglich vorstellen kann, dass das, dass das so wirklich die Reise in die Gesetzbücher äh,
antritt. Also zumal ich auch das für so auf so vielen Ebenen für anfechtbar halte, nicht nur politisch anfechtbar, sondern auch juristisch äh anfechtbar, was da die Bevorzugung et cetera äh betrifft, nicht, weil es einfach so ein,
eingeschränkter Kreis von äh Gruppen ist und das,
im Gesetz nicht sein, dass eben so ein Einzelfall quasi zum Gesetz erhoben wird und das erscheint's mir an dieser Stelle schon fast zu sein.
Ja, also es ist relativ eindeutig so. Es gibt ja zumindest die Theorie,
die, sage ich mal, so von einigen Leuten kolportiert wird, wo ich aber überhaupt nicht sagen kann, was da was da dran ist, dass dieser Vorschlag absichtlich,
so schlecht ist, dass er quasi scheitert,
Aber die FDP quasi sagen kann, hier wir haben alles gemacht für euch, damit sie in den nächsten ähm.
Verstehe, dass sie dann doch nicht runtergezogen werden von denen.
Damit sie von denen von, damit sie irgendwie Qualification von den von den Presseverlagen bekommen, wenn die nächste Wahl ist,
Wie gesagt, das äh kann ich, das sind äh.
Schöne Verschwörungstheorie.
Schöne Verschwörungstheorie, ja, die da also jemand entfaltet, den ich eben auch nicht zitieren kann und das ist also wird sich's zeigen wie, also ich meine, es wäre wirklich ein Spiel mit dem Feuer, wenn diese ähm wenn diese Theorie zutreffe,
Aber äh so so weit äh reichen da jetzt schon die Verschwörungstheorien. Ansonsten tut's mir jetzt echt leid, dass ich den Artikel, wo ich diese wo ich das gelesen habe, ich weiß nicht, ob der jetzt verlinkt ist oder nicht, weil ich hier nicht genau weiß, wo es geschrieben war. Ähm,
wo sie gesagt wurde, dass eigentlich, sage ich mal,
wirklichen Presseverlage im Sinne von, also sagen wir mal, äh fast Spiegel oder sonst was, die die also, sage ich mal, journalistische Arbeit leisten, dass denen eigentlich das Leistungsschutzrecht relativ egal ist,
oder dass sie es nicht haben wollen und es aber eine Tendenz bei den ähm Boulevard Sachen gibt,
Und äh das wurde damit begründet, dass natürlich sowas wie die Bild, ich meine, mit so einem Snippet auf Google News, ist halt der Inhalt eines Bild-Artikels auch erschlagen, ja. Das heißt, die können halt.
Ist.
Und, und, und, und, am, am spannendsten sind bei denen ohnehin die Überschriften. Das heißt, es ist wirklich so, dass sage ich mal der äh, sagen wir fünfundachtzig Prozent des, des Erzeugnisses in so einem Google News äh Snippet äh tatsächlich dann ähm erschlagen werden,
und äh das, was es beim Boulevard tatsächlich äh vielleicht links und Visits kostet,
Während das bei, sage ich mal, einem durchschnittlichen Intellekt angemessenen äh Journalismus,
genau nicht der Fall ist, ja, sondern dass da natürlich der der der Titel nur der Appetizer auf den Inhalt ist, während ähm,
Bei Spiegel ja äh bei bei Spiegel auch manchmal, bei Bild hauptsächlich der der Titel eigentlich schon über den Inhalt hinausgeht und dem Inhalt eigentlich nochmal ein bisschen zurückgerudert werden muss.
Ja, ja, genau.
Sodass äh,
Das fand ich eine ganz ähm fand ich auf jeden Fall eine eine sehr ähm zutreffende Beobachtung,
Und es deckt sich auch ungefähr mit dem, wenn man sich mal anschaut, wer äh tatsächlich dann äh aktiv lobbyiert für dieses Leistungsschutzrecht.
Also es, es ist schon erstaunlich, wie stark jetzt auch so der Widerstand aus der Wirtschaft selber ist. Also ich äh sehe jetzt hier auch gerade auch der Bundesverband der deutschen Industrie, äh hat sich dagegen ausgesprochen, spricht von zahlreichen problematischen Regelungen und Unschärfen,
Und ähm,
Naja, was halt genau gewerblich ist und Verbindung, also was wir hier auch schon ja ausführlich äh in der letzten Folge äh äh besprochen haben. Zusammen mit ähm,
Philipp Otto, einfach das,
Das ist einfach, das ist einfach wischiwaschi, ist von vorne bis hinten, dass einfach da gar nichts klar ist und, und, und, und
am Ende einfach da nur äh Abmahnanwälte letzten Endes da was von haben, weil einfach unklare Regelungen führen einfach zu unklaren Handlungen und das führt dann wiederum einfach zu einer Abmahnwelle.
Das ist schon echt krass.
Also ich denke, dass sie, es ist relativ offensichtlich, wenn sie's machen, mit diesem Leistungsschutzrecht, dass dass hauptsächlich die Presseverlage darunter leiden werden.
Fragt sich wie das Verbraucherschutzministerium zu sowas äh stehen kann, ne? Ich meine, an der Stelle, wo äh grade versucht wurde, die ganze Abmahngeschichte äh in den Griff zu kriegen, ja und jetzt ist schon wieder absehbar, dass die nächste Welle losschlägt. Das ist,
Wäre auch mal ein interessantes Statement.
Man erwarten, dass sie da nochmal ein Wort zu sagen, ja.
Na ja, aber alle halten's Maul. So.
Neues von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Unser Lieblingsthema.
Ja, geht.
Ich glaube vor zwei oder drei Wochen hatten wir ja vermeldet, dass irgendwie festgestellt wurde, dass äh die äh Klage gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie von Digital Rights Irland, Iroland, das sind jetzt nur ihren, ja, also nicht
Königreich, sondern ihren.
Ja ja. Irland.
Dass die äh diese Klage von der ja eigentlich immer geredet wurde oder diese Beschwerde, dass die irgendwie anhängig ist, dass dann festgestellt wurde, du die gibt's ja gar nicht,
und jetzt äh ist sie aber tatsächlich entdeckt worden. Das heißt, da ist also äh die Beschwerde von Digital Rights ist jetzt am EUGH vorgelegt worden, hat da irgendwie eine Nummer
und ähm jetzt muss man halt sehen, ob ob äh der EuGH das Ding annimmt oder nicht. Die eine Neuigkeit, dann ähm,
erklärte irgendwie rosa Barcelo äh von der Generaldirektion Informationsgesellschaft der EU Kommission.
Generaldirektion, Informationsgesellschaft. Sowas gibt es.
Offensichtlich. Also da ist halt eine rosa Barcelo und die sagte bei einer öffentlichen Veranstaltung, dass es noch nicht einmal die Notwendigkeit, dass noch nicht einmal die Notwendigkeit einer Neufassung der Richtlinie beschlossene Sache sei
Also auch wieder hier genau dieser Punkt, worüber wir eigentlich ähm redeten, dass dass ja eine Überarbeitung der Richtlinie
in Aussicht gestellt wird. Wir erinnern uns, da gab's ja dann diese das spielt hier eine Rolle bei der Debatte um äh Deutschland soll Deutschland jetzt Strafzahlungen bekommen oder nicht.
Die Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger sagte ja dann bezüglich dieser Richtlinie
dass es äh sinnvoll wäre, wenn äh Frau Mainstream sich einfach mal darauf besinnen würde, äh sich an diese Überarbeitung
zu setzen. Die Anfrage überhaupt an ihrem Friedrich war äh damit begründet, dass diese Richtlinie evaluiert werden soll zu ihrer Überarbeitung und jetzt äh stellt sich eben raus, ähm,
oder jetzt wird gesagt, dass eine Neufassung überhaupt nicht beschlossen ist, beschlossene Sache sei.
IM Friedrich gesagt.
Innenminister Friedrich. Und ähm.
Unser inoffizieller Mitarbeiter.
Nein, Innenminister hat ja Entschuldigung, ich bitte mich. Also, was unterstützen wir denn da? Ja, aber hier, genau.
Dein.
Apropos äh apropos äh hier in Friedrich, ähm der äh meldete sich dann jetzt zu Wort. Und zwar ging es, äh tauchte irgendwie in den letzten Tagen ein äh äh Twitter-Account auf,
nannte sich irgendwie Piraten online und war irgendwie so ein Fake äh Twitter-Account. Ich finde ja Fact Twitter-Accounts immer cool. In diesem Fall war er nur so mittelcool, weil er irgendwie so ausländerfeindlich,
und dann irgendwie unter anderem ein Tweet absetzte, äh dass Mesut Özil kein Deutscher wäre,
weil irgendwie Papier reicht da nicht ist noch keine Herkunft, das wär trotzdem Türke oder so. So und.
Arschlöcher halt.
Irgendwelchen Scheiß auf Twitter, ja? Und dann kommt äh Friedrich und sagt, ja ähm,
gibt der Osnabrück neuen Osnabrücker Zeitung ein Interview und äh sagt dann ja, das ist ja nur die Spitze des Eisbergs, Verwahrlosung und der Umgangsform Internet ist erschreckend und ähm ja ähm.
Leider äh mangels Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ne. Könnte man jetzt, äh wer die Aussicht, diese Täter, die diesen Fake-Account gemacht haben,
ähm zu erwischen relativ gering. Ja, das ist natürlich unsinnig, mein äh,
sie da wegen wegen Hatespeech äh sich an Twitter wenden, dann dauert das nicht lange, bis sie die äh zugehörige E-Mail-Adresse haben. Äh Twitter wird ihnen sicherlich auch gerne die IP-Adresse rausgeben. Also das wäre jetzt äh
sofern es sich da um ein Verbrechen handelt,
wenn man feststellt, dass Mesut Özil keine deutsch keiner deutschen Herkunft ist, so,
dann wäre es sicherlich auch kein Problem dieser Täter habhaft zu werden,
realistisch betrachtet, ähm ist das aber, glaube ich, eine Feststellung, die noch vom, nicht nur vom Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung, sondern unter Umständen sogar als eine Tatsachenbehauptung geschützt sein könnte. Ähm,
Wenn man feststellt, dass das er eben nicht deutscher Herkunft ist. Wie gesagt, das ist ein völlig irrelevanter
Killifit, ja? Das äh mein der Gedanke, der dahinter steht offenbart, dass das ein verdämliche Nazis sind. Aber es ist auch, äh wir haben ja jetzt nicht gesagt, äh wir müssen hier irgendwie den,
zuleibe rücken oder so. Na ja, also inzwischen, Fake Twitter-Accounts reichen inzwischen aus, äh damit wir eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung brauchen,
und ähm ansonsten, was ich dann noch ganz schön fand.
Rudern, aber auch schon wirklich mit den Armen, ne?
Ja, äh ich habe ich denn dieses schöne ah,
Es gab da noch so ein schönes Zitat von dem von dem Vater von Mesut Özil, der dann sagte, äh ja, stell dir mal vor, als nächstes geht hier auf die Kehdira, Lukas Podolski und zählte dann mal alle ähm,
Fußballer, Nichtdeutscher, Herkunft in der deutschen Fußballnationalmannschaft ähm auf, also eigentlich ganz witzig für so für so Nazis, die müssen ja durchdrehen.
Klose, Podolski.
Du kennst die, ich kenne die, also du kennst diese Mannschaft, aber da da sind halt wahrscheinlich relativ viele bei, ne? Also Boateng.
Ah, ohne Ende. Ja, ja, das mittlerweile ist es echt durch Kakao,
teilweise wie eine brasilianische Mannschaft. Ja und und scheiß drauf. Ich meine so so ist das halt. Ich meine es sind halt die Leute, die eben jetzt hier sozialisiert sind und die sich eben mit uns hier äh verbunden fühlen und dann sind das halt einfach Deutsche.
Ich bin ja auch Deutscher, ob für dich kein Deutscher aufm Papier bin.
Ich möchte, ich lege Wert auf die Feststellung, dass das äh dass die dann nicht als Deutsche für Deutschland spielen, sondern als äh Vertreter des deutschen DFB,
Und damit ist das auch völlig egal, wer da spielt, ja. Das ist, das ist, ich ich weigere mich, dass irgendwie so ein national.
Egal wer da spielt, ne? Also ist schon der Richtige auf dem.
Schon Tor schießen, ja.
Viertelfinale, mein Freund.
Ja lass uns.
Ja, wir sollten vielleicht auch Fußballergebnisse durchsagen, weil wir sowieso hier jede Woche unsere Fußballpolitik. Genau.
Fußballpolitik. Nein, also Kern,
ist, also irgendwelche Spinner machen irgendeinen blöden Twitter-Account, der irgendwie eigentlich keine Sau äh interessiert und da, vor allem, weil er ja die Piraten in den direkt so kam, dann wahrscheinlich alle
zwanzigtausend Piraten, äh die auf Twitter sind, äh sofort auf äh Block and Report, vor Spam äh geklickt und der Account war in kürzester Zeit weg. Ähm
ist eigentlich erbärmlich, dass dass sich ein Innenminister zu zu so einer Thematik überhaupt äußert. Und es ist lächerlich, sowas so äh hochzubauschen, dass irgendwelche, irgendwelche,
verwirrten da irgendwas äh irgendwas twittern. Ja. Das äh das ist eigentlich das das Erschreckende daran, dass das so dass so ein,
Killefit überhaupt Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt wird.
Säuft's.
Hatte ich da noch irgendwas zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung? Ja äh hier der ähm,
Der AK Vorrat hat dann mal äh nochmal eine,
Eine Studie der oder eine Zusammenfassung der Bundesnetzagentur äh hier thematisiert eine Erhebung. Ähm.
In denen mal festgestellt wird, dass wie lange und was Mobilfunk Provider speichern. Und ähm die speichern,
offensichtlich die Funkzellen, an denen Handys genutzt werden, das war ja auch eigentlich relativ klar, sonst wird ja dieser ganze stille SMS-Kram äh äh nicht wirklich äh funktionieren,
und äh zwar macht Vodafone das bis zu zweihundertzehn Tage lang. Das heißt ähm die haben dann ähm,
offensichtlich zweihundertzehn Tage lang dort protokolliert, wo man sich zum Zeitpunkt von Kommunikation mit dem Netz, also empfangen von,
SMS oder Anruf oder ausgehend aufgehalten hat, das wär das sind ja im Prinzip Dinge, die auch in der Vorratsdatensprechung so vorgesehen worden wären. Es findet offensichtlich statt.
E plus achtzig Tage Telekom, dreißig Tage. Außerdem speichern sie wohl auch ähm die ausgehenden Verbindungen und das selbst bei Nutzung eines Pauschaltarifs.
Ähm
für ähnlich lange dauert, ja. Ziemlich genau die gleiche Dauer. Ähm das heißt, äh obwohl ich eigentlich einen Vertrag habe, der äh es mir ermöglicht, so viel zu telefonieren, wie ich das für richtig halte. Äh protokollieren die über äh ja,
zwischen dreißig und zweihundertzehn Tage lang mit wem ich tatsächlich telefoniert habe, obwohl es eigentlich keinen Grund gibt, das ähm für die Abrechnung zu tun. Ja, es gibt sind Daten ähm,
die an der Stelle,
nicht sinnvoll zu erheben sind oder oder eigentlich deren Erhebung nicht sinnvoll begründet werden kann. Außer natürlich ähm.
Dass das für sie ja vielleicht auch ganz interessante Informationen sind, einfach für das wirtschaftliche Data Mining.
Genau, so irgendwie wie wo werden unsere Netze am meisten benutzt und äh so was.
Genau, ich meine, das ist ja das andere Problem. Es ist ja jetzt nicht nur so, dass es ein staatliches Interesse gibt an ähm Datenspeicherungen, ja. Äh ich würde jetzt auch mal nicht sagen, auf Vorrat im Sinne von einer zukünftigen ähm
Verwendungen, sondern einer Langzeitspeicherung zwecks einer statistischen Auswertung. Die ich in gewisser Hinsicht auch,
Ähm wie soll ich sagen, sofern sie anonymisiert ist, ausreichend anonymisiert ist für absolut sinnvoll halte. Weil,
Klar, wenn man Mobilfunknetz betreibt, dann möchte man natürlich auch sehr viel darüber wissen, wie es genutzt wird,
Um es einfach entsprechend gut ausbauen zu können, ne, voraussagen, zu treffen. Und das ist natürlich klar, dass man sich dann äh eben diese ganzen Bewegungsdaten,
anschaut. Es muss halt nur konsequent gemacht werden und eben entsprechend anonymisiert werden. Ich meine, letztlich zum Beispiel auch keiner auf,
wahrscheinlich regt sich doch irgendjemand die Ruhe auf, aber meiner Meinung nach nicht, äh wenn dann nicht gerechtfertigterweise, dass zum Beispiel auch die ganzen Bewegungsdaten verwendet werden für äh Verkehrs,
Aussagen. Ich meine, wenn man heute mit dem Tom durch die Gegend fährt und äh sagt, ich will hier nach B, ja, dann sagt er, ja, fahr mal nicht da lang, weil da ist grad Stau.
Diese Information kommt halt letzten Endes da.
Sind jetzt zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe. Ähm also dieses, dass die dass die das Tomton irgendwie guckt, wo halten wir uns die ganze Zeit auf?
Und wo scheint ein Stau zu sein? Ist natürlich 'ne sehr 'ne sehr sinnvolle Sache, das das lässt sich ja auch anonymisiert machen als Mobilfunkbetreiber kann ich, brauche ich nicht die Einzelverbindungsdaten aller,
aller meiner Netzteilnehmer um zu gucken wo mein Netz belastet ist, das ist 'ne Information die kann mir auch die einzelne Zelle,
sehr viel einfacher auszuwerten, äh bereitstellen und ähm,
ähm selbst wenn ich das jetzt aus der Zelle nicht extrahieren könnte, was man ja mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr einfach machen kann, ähm,
ist eben noch lange kein Grund, dass ich jetzt das auf die Person bezogen und für eine solche Dauer ähm und absolut nicht anonymisiert mache, ne. Also wenn ich.
Nee, ist klar, es ist nur so, ich denke, dass bei den Firmen manchmal auch einfach so eine gewisse Faulheit,
so mentale Faulheit vorliegt. So nach dem Motto, na wir speichern das mal alles so, dann können wir später mal gucken, was wir draus machen.
Man ist, das hat sich natürlich schon ein bisschen geändert, das war in Deutschland sicherlich auch immer schon ein bisschen anders, aber das ist natürlich auch, dass das eigentlich,
quasi Vorratsdatenspeicherung zwangsläufig irgendwie dabei abfallen, weil es einfach so diesen äh privaten,
Hunger gibt und man im Zeugsfall erstmal lieber mehr speichert als weniger. Ne, also dass diese Datensparsamkeit, die mangelnde äh dann auch die Ursache sein kann,
dass eben ja am Ende äh so etwas wie eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung tatsächlich durchgeführt wird, wenn auch nicht staatlich beauftragt oder verpflichten.
Ja. So, also gibt's, dann gibt's nochmal verlinkt eine schöne Seite,
wo man sich das anschauen kann mit der Speicher gibt's jetzt natürlich dann auch irgendwelche Beschwerden, dass das gerechtfertigt werden soll und so. Aber man wird sich ähm denke ich auch mittelfristig nicht wirklich,
von der Problematik ähm der oder den Problemen, die mit Datenspeicherungen einhergehen,
befreien, ja? Also das das Problem wird irgendwie bleiben, genau wie du es hast, dass es eben auch ganz andere Interessen gibt, ja, solche Daten einfach mal zu erheben und.
Genau. Na gut, dann können wir das, glaube ich, jetzt auch abschließen hier mit den äh Vorratsdaten. Was jetzt hier noch eine letzte äh kleinen Nachtrag.
Ich habe noch äh mir ist noch was eingefallen und zwar ähm wurde vor einige Monate her, ähm da ist der,
Podcastbus, Podcastbus von Metronaut,
ins Wendland gefahren und hat von dort ähm Podcastaufnahmen mit denen äh dort gegen den Castor Transport protestierenden Personen gemacht und ähm auch irgendwie für das radiofreies Wendland haben sie dort produziert.
Und äh ihnen wurde dann der Bus beschlagnahmt, inklusive kompletten.
Frisch neu gekauften Equipment.
Frisch gekauften Podcast-Equipment drin und zwar zur Gefahrenabwehr. Und,
Sie haben sich jetzt entschlossen, gegen diese Beschlagnahme zu klagen. Ähm,
und eigentlich gibt's für die, also wir wollen natürlich irgendwie Pressefreiheit nach Artikel fünf äh irgendwie durchsetzen, dass diese Beschlagnahme illegal war. Da da gibt's für die eigentlich nicht viel zu holen, außer eben Recht zu haben und äh das wird sie sicherlich auch ein bisschen
Geld kosten, das zu machen und Sie haben da jetzt ein Spendenkonto und 'n Flatterknopf,
und ähm die Berichterstattung zu dem Thema ähm kann ich auch nochmal verlinken, wer das für Unterstützungs unterstützenswert hält. Ähm der kann da gerne was hinspenden.
Okay, verlinken wir. Brauchst du noch was?
Ja, das äh ist jetzt das Thema, was äh da verweise ich nur nochmal drauf, weil wir es hatten und zwar die Loriot Briefmarken, da gab's jetzt vom Landgericht Berlin
Urteil, dass also der Loriot Airbin Recht gegeben hat, gegenüber der ähm dem Wikipe,
Media EV, der da wahrscheinlich die Wikipedia vertreten hat, ähm dass,
die Loriot Briefmarken auch tatsächlich nicht ähm in der Wikipedia gezeigt werden können dürfen sollen. Und ähm,
Die Begründung ist etwas komplizierter, deswegen verlinke ich das jetzt nur mal. Ähm,
wurde letztendlich ging es darum, dass dadurch, dass dieses Motiv auf einer auf einer Briefmarke ist, es trotzdem ein ähm,
urheberrechtlich ist und dann gibt's noch die Unterscheidung zwischen Texten und äh Werken der bildenden Kunst. Das wird also relativ komplex, also auf jeden Fall Landgericht Berlin hat in diesem Fall der
Er bin da Recht gegeben, wer das wer das im Detail lesen möchte, der findet den Link auf dem Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Genau, Logbuch Strich Netzpolitik Punkt DE, eure Webseite zur Beantwortung aller entscheidenden Fragen aus Kulturgesellschaft, Politik et cetera.
So, ist anscheinend noch keine Entscheidung aus Ecuador. Insofern müssen wir, komm, Tipp, nehmen die den oder nicht? Eier auf den Tisch.
Gute Frage. Ähm ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das ich habe da gar keine Meinung zu.
So können wir nicht wetten.
Nee, das stimmt. Aber ich wüsste jetzt auch gar nicht, welcher der beiden Varianten ich äh die höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit gebe. Mir ist es äh mein Knackpunkt ist, dass ich nicht so genau einschätzen kann, welche Möglichkeiten ich meine, angenommen sie entscheiden sich jetzt dazu,
Auf Basis welchen also ist es sozusagen der diplomatische Kodex erlaubt es einem Land,
aus eine beliebige Person, egal in welchem Rechtskonflikt die gerade mit dem Gastgeberland steht, einfach aus diesem Land zu entfernen? Oder ist es so, dass dann Britannien auch sagen muss, ah okay, äh Asyl,
Na dann nimmt ihn mal mit.
Ich denke nicht. Also ich bin ähm,
Also das ist ja das ist ja genau die Frage. So, wenn die jetzt sagen, wir haben den jetzt und die sagen, der ist jetzt bei uns, der hat jetzt bei uns Asyl, ja? Dann ähm müsste,
Das Vereinigte Königreich sah ja erstmal sagen, warum sie den denn da behalten wollen, was sie gegen den haben und sie haben ja nix Offizielles,
theoretisch würde ich das jetzt schon so interpretieren, dass die das Völkerrecht in dieser Situation irgendwie vor, sind wir da man merkt, ich habe überhaupt gar keine Ahnung, was Völkerrecht ist, aber das äh sage ich mal so, der der äh die.
Da ist ja nichts nicht so, dass nichts vorliegt. Es liegt ja auch was vor. Ich meine, es hat ja genug vorgelegen, um ihn irgendwie jetzt in anderthalb Jahren in der Fußfessel durch die Gegend laufen äh zu lassen. Also so,
es gibt vielleicht keinen Strafantrag gegen ihn und es liegt nichts jetzt selbst vor, aber ist ja auch nicht so, dass die keinerlei Vorgaben hätten, dass sie jetzt auf einmal keine Akte mehr finden,
Assange, wie schreiben Sie das? ASS? Nee, da haben wir nichts.
Der Witz ist nur also ich fänd's halt, also das könnte halt wirklich und das denke ich auch, je nachdem wie die das jetzt spielen, kann das halt wirklich zu einer diplomatischen Krise führen,
und zwar richtig. Oder aber ähm die äh das Vereinigte Königreich sagt, ey, zum Glück sind wir den Spinat so. Komm, ähm pack den hier in den Hubschrauber und weg mit dem. Ich habe keine Lust mehr.
Amerikaner gehen wahrscheinlich doch sowieso schon die ganze Zeit auf den Sack. Äh deswegen so nach dem Motto hier, schickt ihr mal nach Schweden, das passt schon.
Ja.
Und erstmal raus aus dem Common Wales so, weil wir so kommen willst Mitglieder äh ausliefern so, ist ja eh nicht so angesagt, ne? Ist eh alles ein bisschen absurd,
Hat bestimmt auch schon irgendwie heiße Telefonleitung. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, inwieweit die das interessiert,
So, erstmal sitzt ja da unten auch, sag mal, ich
bin mir jetzt so äh Equador, ich habe das nicht so richtig verfolgt, wie sich das so politisch da entwickelt hat, aber so grundsätzlich da so links oben in Südamerika, da hat jetzt die USA jetzt nicht so das Pfund in der letzten Zeit so, ne.
Also die, ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass das das Equadorische Volk äh so grundsätzlich, wenn der Assanger da landet, dass da durchaus irgendwie auch mal einer am Flughafen steht und sagt, hey hallo, winken wir mal.
Ja, das kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Über den roten Teppich.
Mehr,
Was würde ihm bestimmt gefallen? Naja gut, also wir wünschen ihm ja auch nichts äh Schlimmes, weil man kann ihm ja vorwerfen, was man will, ja? Aber Ihnen jetzt wie ein
Schwerstverbrecher zu behandeln ist sicherlich unangemessen. Das sage ich jetzt mal ganz unabhängig von,
Sachen, die da in Schweden anhängig sind, weil,
das kann ich überhaupt nicht einschätzen, was da äh passiert ist oder nicht. Und gewisser Hinsicht, muss ich sagen, wäre es mir fast lieb, auch für diese ganze Wikileaks-Bewegungsgeschichte an sich, dass das mal,
Erklärung überführt wird.
Ja, es sind ja auch zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe, also.
Weil wenn da, ne, das ist wirklich was vollkommen anderes, aber das hängt immer wie so ein Darmluklusschwert auch über dieser ganzen Bewegung und das das das hat dem nicht nicht gut getan, ne.
Ja
Also, spannende Sache. Spannende Situation und ich bin wirklich äh also ich ich muss sagen, solche solche Situationen wie wie die in der Equador sich jetzt befindet, die ähm kann ich stundenlang drüber philosophieren. Also so dieses,
äh was so die sind halt in einer Situation, wo sie auf jeden Fall nur noch eine Entscheidung treffen können, die ihnen ziemlich viel Ärger einhandelt.
War gut, aber das ist wahrscheinlich eh so.
Es sei denn, die erschießen ihnen einfach stand rechtliche Botschaftskarten so. Kriegen sie aber auch Ärger.
Auweia. Vielleicht sollten wir weiter diskutieren, wenn wir hier auch erwachsen geworden sind. Nämlich in der dreißigsten Ausgabe von Notbuch-Netzpolitik und ich hoffe, ihr seid auch wieder äh mit dabei. Schalten sie wieder ein, wenn sie die Nuss sagen hören,
Bis bald. Ciao, ciao.
Ciao, ciao.